l'ukraine on en débat tout de suite dans
ce sens public on va notamment parlé de
la stratégie de la lumière poutine du
siège des grandes villes alors qu'un
immeuble de kiev a été bombardé
aujourd'hui mais d'abord un bilan du
sommet de versailles et des sanctions
supplémentaires que l'europe peut
éventuellement décider avec norbert
évangélistes
les dirigeants européens réunis en
conseil de crise à versailles ce week
end ont fixé un cap celui d'une europe
souveraine pleinement assumé charge à la
commission européenne cette fois de
passer à l'action pour donner corps à
l'objectif des vingt-sept principal
levier à sa disposition réduire les
dépendances de l'union en matière
d'énergie d'abord face à une guerre dont
nul n'est capable de prédire l'issue et
dont les conséquences se font sentir un
peu plus chaque jour l'urgence commande
d'agir au plus vite nous allons proposer
dans les quinze jours qui viennent à la
demande du conseil une réduction très
significative de dépendance du gaz russe
c'est de passer de 9% donc à 3% d'ici la
fin de l'année avec un passage obligé à
au mois d'octobre pour augmenter très
significativement l'ensemble de nos
réserves de gaz et qu'elle soit plein à
90% avant de rentrer dans l'hiver donc
c'est un enjeu majeur de façon à le
faire de façon plus mutualisés en outre
pour aider les particuliers à faire face
à la flambée des prix le conseil a voulu
mettre à la disposition des états
membres une série de mesures comme
celles de taxer les entreprises de
l'énergie premières bénéficiaires de la
hausse des prix tout ce qui va dans le
sens
aujourd'hui je dirais d'une aide non
seulement pour les particuliers mais
aussi pour les entreprises pour les
secteurs pour des secteurs qui sont plus
touchés que d'autres pas dans le bon
sens et c'est vrai qu'ils semblent
parfaitement les cimes en tout cas la
commission a estimé que c'était légitime
sait plus bien sûr ça fait partie aussi
des propositions qui ont à la
disposition des états membres on les
incite effectivement à les utiliser en
matière de défense les vingt-sept ont
voulu présenter un ali plus fort au sein
de l'otan dès l'invasion de l'ukraine
par vladimir poutine l'allemagne et
d'autres pays du nord de l'europe ont
aussitôt abondé le but j'ai de leur
défense le but est maintenant d'étendre
cette mesure à l'ensemble de l'union on
le sait aujourd'hui beaucoup d'états
membres ont enfin annoncé qu'ils
allaient passer à 2% de leur produit
intérieur brut consacré à la défense ce
cas la commission en particulier moi
même qui sut les commissaires chargés d
un disque défense demandait depuis
longtemps donc enfin ces 2 % sont en vue
ça veut dire par parenthèse que si tout
le monde monte à 2 % est-ce que je pense
qu'il va se passer on va donc investir
tous les ans entre 65 et 70 milliards
d'euros de plus pour la défense alors
que la guerre redouble de violence aux
portes de l'europe l'heure est bien à la
mobilisation pour preuve le calendrier
des vingt-sept s'accélère un conseil
exceptionnel de défense prévus au mois
de mai devrait donner lieu à d'autres
prises de décision fin mars un nouveau
sommet confirmera des propositions
concrètes en matière d'énergie
le bilan de ce sommet de versailles mais
aussi la stratégie de vladimir poutine
voilà les deux thèmes principaux de ce
débat avec pascale joannin bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directrice générale
de la fondation schuman j'accueille
également benjamin haddad bonsoir
directeur du centre europe du cercle de
réflexion atlantic council chercheur en
relations internationales auteur du
paradis perdu l'amérique de trump et la
fin des illusions européennes c'était
chez grasset christian makarian bon soin
liste des questions internationales
éditorialiste au point et à radio
notre-dame matthieu croissandeau est
toujours à mes côtés
re bonsoir mathieu peut-être un petit
bilan de ceux de ce sommet de versailles
pascal johanna pour commencer alors le
sommet de versailles c'était un sommet
en effet qui était prévu non qui ne sait
pas donc fait parce qu'il ya eu la
guerre sur rennes inciter à l'agenda
sauf qu'au lieu de parler de croissance
d'investissement
essayer de de parler de nos économies on
a parlé donc économie bien sûr mais plus
dans deux termes de comment on résiste
aux sanctions et qu'elles sont des
sanctions qu'on développe si on en a
besoin on a vu depuis qu'il y avait de
nouvelles sanctions qu'ils avaient été
prises on a parlé bien entendu défense
puisque vous l'avez dit dans votre
reportage des états membres qui
s'étaient plus engagées en matière de
défense on se dirait radicalement de
guide et l'allemagne ou les pays du
monde est ce que vous pensez que de
réelles avancées alors il ya eu des
annonces très très timide parce que
comme vous l'avez peut-être ainsi au
compris le conseil européen donne une
impulsion mais c'est pas lui qui décide
leur après les derniers points ces
énergies donc il ya en effet un certain
nombre de choses qui maintenant sont
transmises à la commission la commission
dans l'union européenne a le monopole de
l'initiative
donc là elle a reçu une lettre de
mission c'est grandir de la part des
vingt-sept qui nous faisait une émission
politique en disant maintenant il faut
qu'on mette en place tout ça en matière
énergétique et en effet il faut réduire
la dépendance en matière de défense il
faut réduire la dépendance lors non plus
que à vis du gaz russe mais vis-à-vis
peut-être des américains parce que on se
rend compte que les amis à des
américains l'ukraine c'est loin ils ont
toujours dit depuis plusieurs présidents
trump obama que leur pivot stasi que
l'europe donc si jamais nous on a des
intérêts à défendre
est ce qu'on saura les faire tous seuls
6 e décide que c'est pas leurs intérêts
et donc c'est un peu ce bilan est donc
face à la situation c'est réduire la
dépendance et donc prendre des mesures
donc là en effet le commissaire orpea
thierry breton qui chargent de plein de
choses à la commission a en effet un
travail intense à faire dans quinze
jours pour essayer de faire en sorte que
le parlement européen ait bien compris
et le conseil puisse adore puisque
l'état puisse prendre des décisions ce
qui est drôle c'est que d'un seul coup
on s'était presque entre guillemets
jedir habitués mais à des décisions
rapides une année à toulouse il a le
rythme européen manifestement reprend le
dessus benjamin haddad des critiques
plus ou moins fortes sur le faste du
château de versailles dans ce dans ce
contexte est ce que vous voulez partager
ce pas le plus important mais qu'est ce
que vous en dites ça non pas du tout où
déjà je pense que c'est important d'en
jouir de ce mec la france joue sur ses
atouts et le schéma de versailles
finalement en fait partie et puis je
crois que c'est des critiques qui sont
plus liés au contexte de politique
intérieure le français très particulier
dans lequel évidemment sauver de
versailles s'est tenue même taux que
semer versailles lui-même j'ai en tout
cas pas du tout entendu c'est crédible
par exemple à l'étranger parmi nos
partenaires mais je crois que ce sommet
a été important effectivement pour
lancer quelques chantiers c'est à dire
que on a vu effectivement des décisions
très rapide sur le court terme qui ont
été prises pour soutenir l'ukraine donc
des paquets de sanctions extrêmement
rapide beaucoup plus rapide par exemple
qu'en 2014 est beaucoup plus large que
soient les sanctions sur les oligarques
contre les avoirs de la banque centrale
russe détenue à l'étranger le death with
stage de quelques quelques bancs et
aussi les livraisons d'armes à l'ukraine
des décisions historiques qui ont été
prises par quelques états membres sur
les questions de défense on en parle et
là dans le reportage l'allemagne mais
aussi la suède le danemark ou encore la
pologne qui monte à 3 % du pib son
budget de défense ça je dirais que
c'était les chantiers à court terme et
le sommet de versailles permis je pense
de lancer après les chantiers à plus
long terme si en plus structurelle parce
que ce qu'on a réussi à faire assez
rapidement par exemple sur les sanctions
l'intéressé c'est vrai que c'est allé
vite mais c'est des décisions sur
lesquelles on a assez rapidement réussi
à trouver des consensus et là on arrive
un peu dans le dur sur les questions
d'europe de la défense sur les questions
de dépendance énergétique
même des divisions historiques de
l'union européenne à surmonter et c'est
là effectivement qu'il va falloir
impulser des politiques long terme pour
réduire à zéro notre dépendance au gaz
russe effectivement on peut pas le faire
du jour au lendemain on sait que c'est
très important c'est très important
parce que c'est aujourd'hui que trésor
de guerre sur lequel s'appuie vladimir
poutine pour continuer son agression
côté ukrainien mais c'est très important
aussi par ça c'est une question de
souveraineté européenne on sait que
l'énergie est utilisée par la russie non
pas comme un bien sur un marché entre
des clients les fournisseurs mais comme
une arme politique comme un levier
d'influencé dans nos démocraties donc
c'est un enjeu de souveraineté
européenne mais ça veut dire
effectivement trouver d'autres
fournisseurs ça veut dire diversifié ça
veut dire avertir dans les renouvelables
dans le nucléaire tout ça ça prend du
temps ça se fait pas du jour au
lendemain ça c'est un des chantiers un
autre chantier c'est effectivement celui
de la défense européenne il ya des
initiatives historiques qui ont été
prises au niveau des états membres donc
c'est vrai quand on dit qu'on a fait
plus en quelques jours qu'en trente ans
c'est vrai et maintenant comment est ce
qu'on arrive à coordonner tout cela au
niveau européen je crois que ça l'est
c'est un des enjeux des prochains mois
certains parlent par exemple d'un
nouveau fonds de résilience honda effet
un fonds de résilience après le coc vide
dans ses relances
là on ferait un fonds de résilience qui
pourrait peut-être permettre aussi
d'investir dans les capacités de défense
là il va y avoir un certain nombre de
partenaires à convaincre mais je pense
que ça fait partie des chantiers de long
terme qui sont lancés par ce sommet
effectivement c'est là dessus je voulais
vous entendre christian makarian c'est
cette question de l'endettement parce
que là c'est quand même assez dingue si
on prend un peu de recul le le le
bouleversement que ceux se ses trois
semaines presque trois semaines de
conflit
ont pu provoquer les bouleversements
l'europe s'était endetté collectivement
pour réagir à la crise que vides c'est
possible qu on ait une seconde phase d'
endettement collectif alors que c'était
vraiment pas dans le voilà dans le dans
l'adn du foulard lui ont d'après ce que
j'ai compris c'est pas tout à fait le
même schéma d'endettement la solution
les nations qui chacune s'engage à
augmenter la part du budget national
consacré à la défense pour atteindre 2%
le plus rapidement possible ce qui au
passage était une exigence de l'aude
impérative de monsieur donald trump un
parce qu'il avait une crise là dessus
menaçant même de ne plus faire
fonctionner l'article 5 de l'otan en
tout cas c'était une lecture de
l'article 5 c'est là la rue précitée
c'est là servent anciens ou actuels fait
ce qui est un état et agressés tous les
autres se porte à son secours et
autrement dit si cet article est pas
respectée il ya mille d'alliance
clairement donc trump a réussi à nous
rendre service rétrospectivement nous
européens ce qu'on va tous passer à 2%
monsieur breton qu'on a entendu tout à
leur dit que la masse des augmentations
si chacune des 27 nations passe à 2% et
certaines comme l'a dit maja main tout à
l'heure la pologne passe à 3 parce que
c'est le voisin direct de là on le sait
il ya des états qui sont déjà au dessus
de 3 la grèce par exemple pour des
raisons voisinage turc on peut
comprendre bon ça a été reproché à la
grèce dans le sahara questions
d'endettement global mais si on
additionne tout monsieur breton chiffres
ça à 70 milliards
ça fait tilt immédiatement parce que 70
milliards de plus c'est supérieur au
budget russe de la défense qui est de 65
67 milliards ça veut dire que le seul
surcroît de dépenses des 27 nations
allant jusqu'à 2 % de leur budget en
dépenses d'armement ou militaire au sens
large le seul surcroît de dépenses
dépasserait la totalité du budget de la
défense russe c'est donc pas rien c'est
assez différent du schéma de 750
milliards débloqués pour le coc vite qui
correspondait à un an dette de la
commission sur les marchés financiers à
des taux à l'époque faut déjà dire à
l'époque il ya trois ans qui était
ridiculement bas donc c'était une bonne
affaire si je puis dire là c'est tout à
fait différent mais c'est cet été quand
même aussi de proposer paris a par la
hausse des dépenses militaires d'avoir
une forme de plans de résilience et
contre lequel se sont élevées tout un
nombre de nos produits et manu macro à
paris ville et de dollars avec un plan
de résilience fait réflexes sont
ressortis qui est une capitale
extraordinairement créative en matière
de dette publique il faut quand même le
dire et on est et on est obligé de
revenir sur cette question parce que à
cause de la crise coville on a mis sous
cloche un petit peu des règles
européennes
parce que il y avait en effet une
urgence sanitaire et donc on a dit
volontairement qu'on allait mettre
s'abstraire des règles pendant deux ans
donc jusqu'en 2022 donc qu'est ce qu'on
fait en 2023 donc là en effet on se rend
bien compte que face à la nouvelle crise
différente c'est pas du tout la même
chose mais l'adaptation des pays
européens pour certains ou il va être
radical nous en france on est assez
j'allais dire tant sur l'énergie que sur
la défense on n'est pas dans le flou
commun parce que nous avons une
dépendance en matière de défense depuis
longtemps nous possédons l'arme
nucléaire nous avons une armée qui peut
se déployer ce qui n'est pas le cas des
allemands par exemple ou de d'autres
grandes de grands pays européens et en
matière énergétique le choix nucléaire
que nous avons fait depuis plusieurs
années nous rend moins dépendant du gaz
mais pour d'autres pays et donc ça va
vous devine ça va être coûteux parce que
si on fait le gaz mais on ne peut pas le
transporter il ya des méthaniers m'enfin
c'est assez dangereux mais si on oublie
aussi on débloque le gazoduc peut tendre
russie va falloir reconstruire quelque
chose venant d'ailleurs et donc là
peut-être en effet les fonds de relance
qui était mise en place pour le
transition énergétique vont servir aussi
et s'il en manque un peu on pourrait en
rajouter pour aider certains qui sont
aujourd'hui tributaire du gaz russe à
plus de 40% ça résout pas cher pascal le
problème de savoir ce qu'on fait de cet
argent parce que c'est pas parce qu'on
va augmenter les budgets disposer d'une
masse d'argent qui va dépasser je le
répète la totalité du budget de la
défense russe que ce
jeu ça me dit quoi faire quel type
d'armé est-ce qu'il faut une armée
continental classiques comme la mary ce
qu'on voit sur les images qui est un ami
qui est en train de tout détruire on n'a
aucune envie de revenir en arrière et de
reconstruire ce type d'armé on l'avait
on la démanteler est-ce qu'il faut une
armée de projection avec beaucoup plus
de drôles des choses beaucoup plus
technologique est-ce qu'il faut
augmenter la part du cyber de la cip et
du cyber enseignement enfin il ya un
schéma des forces qu'il faudrait
imaginer alors pour le coup de grâce
qu'on ne le pense pas nation par nation
mais pour une fois au niveau de l'union
européenne faire la même stratégie pour
tous les pays fassent voilà au dessus
des os et wii la wii au dessus des
défenses national des 27 pays il
faudrait un schéma commun absolument
collectif au défendre l'union sur des
projets collectifs commun encore un mot
là dessus et après on parle d'énergie
avait 6 mai ça serait un terrain qu'ils
soient m'a carrément parler donc si on
accumule est juste les 70 milliards
seraient plus que le budget russe mais
déjà aujourd'hui quand on cumule tous
les budgets de défense européens on est
le deuxième acteur militaire mondiale
après les états unis est-ce que ça se
traduit en capacité opérationnelle est
ce que ça se traduit en capacité à
pouvoir conduire des missions non
évidemment on le voit bien et le
problème c'est qu'effectivement on a
beaucoup de duplication beaucoup de
redondance et donc être capable ou
d'équipements qui sont pas forcément
compatibles voilà exactement au fur des
longues à nos petits
savoir où est-ce qu'on a effectivement
d'aidé
des besoins de capacités au niveau
européen faire en sorte que ce soit tout
soit intérêt auprès d'ab t rop opérables
et qu'on puisse après mener des
opérations en commun c'est ça vraiment
en fait c'est du clic est absolument
fondamentale et c'est pour ça que
investir en commun et et fléchit les
investissements dans un sens qui
multiplie je dirais l'impact pour tout
le monde ça qui va être important les
prochaines années alors vous avez évoqué
la question de l'indépendance
énergétique steve jourdain peut nous
rejoindre de nouveau sur ce plateau
puisque c'était cette question de
l'indépendance j'ai des énergétique
steve au coeur d'une journée
particulière au sénat aujourd'hui très
particulière puisqu'une conférence
interparlementaire était organisée
aujourd'hui donc au sénat elle
réunissait des représentants d'une
vingtaine de parlements européens
conférence organisée dans le cadre
évidemment de la présidence française de
l'union aux conférences évidemment un
peu spécial qui a commencé par une
minute de silence en l'honneur des
victimes de la guerre on ukraine à
l'ordre du jour thomas l'autonomie
stratégique la question de notre
indépendance vis-à-vis de 6 et thierry
breton qui a ouvert la conférence ce
matin on a entendu tout à l'heure le
commissaire européen au marché intérieur
a rappelé les engagements pris au sommet
de versailles la semaine dernière le gaz
russe représente actuellement 9% du
total du mix énergétique européen
l'objectif est de le réduire à 3% d'ici
à la fin de l'année c'est pas gagné et
au coeur de cette conférence est une
question dont on en reparle pour le
moment assez peu celle de notre
dépendance à la russie concernant ce
qu'on appelle les métaux rares oui ils
sont partout thomas ils sont partout ils
sont dans votre smartphone dans votre
voiture électrique dans vos éoliennes
ils ou plutôt elles se sont donc les
terres dites rares la chine est le
premier producteur mondial mais la
russie en produit également et depuis le
début de la guerre en ukraine et bien le
cours de certains produits a
littéralement bondi la sénatrice les
républicains sophie primas met en garde
écouter la guerre a également fait
bondir le cours de trois métaux en
provenance de russie qui sont
indispensables à nos industriels en
particulier dans la fabrication de
batteries électriques
l'aluminium le palladium et le titane
alors où l'europe entend accélérer en
direction de la transition énergétique
cela nous rappelle la vulnérabilité
induite par cette transition sur le plan
de l'approvisionnement en métaux
critiques le premier défi est celui de
la hausse des prix car le recours aux
métaux rares remporte un risque
inflationniste
cette hausse conjoncturelle pourrait se
muer en hausse structurelle à mesure de
l'avancée de la transition énergétique
voilà donc l'une des conséquences
imprévues de cette guerre en ukraine le
retard ou le potentiel retard en matière
de transition énergétique merci steam il
faut rappeler l'importance de développer
une filière de récupération des métaux
raoult d'été à titre a avec les 110
millions il ya 110 millions de
téléphones portables en france qui
dorment dans les tiroirs là dedans il ya
de la vie il ya des victoires à
récupérer bref je sais que les
entreprises qui s'en occupe sur cette
question benjamin haddad de de
l'indépendance énergétique alors on l'a
déjà dit on va peut-être pas y passer
tout le débat mais c'est quand même
intéressant de dire qu'il ya plusieurs
europe quoi très très très clairement et
plus on va à l'est plus il ya une
dépendance au gaz russe mais sur alors
nous on est beaucoup moins exposé un
notamment parce qu'on a fait le choix du
nucléaire on voit les allemands qui ont
fait un autre choix celui d'abandonner
nucléaire il ya une dizaine d'années
mais aussi avec une forme de connivence
un de certaines élites politiques
allemandes on se rappelle évidemment du
cas de gerhard schröder qui était sur le
conseil distraction de nord stream 2
donc il ya un choix comme en politique
qui a été fait de se rapprocher avec la
russie que les allemands paient
aujourd'hui oui mais on revisite un peu
le bilan de dents que l'américaine est
aussi du logiciel idée des verts
européens et donc un peu des bas mais
totalement vous avez raison alors sur le
bilan d'angela merkel en voie il ya eu
la décision show nucléaire il ya eu
cette lenteur à prendre des décisions
aussi sur les questions de défense
puisque olaf scholz en quelques mois
alors évidemment sous la pression des
événements annonce d'augmenter le budget
de défense à 2% du pib ce qui avait
toujours été un sujet de crise entre les
états unis et l'allemagne notamment sous
donald trump pas uniforme est déjà sous
barack obama demandé aux allemands
d'augmenter leur budget de défense 100
milliards d'investissements en une année
aussi pour les allemands en défense donc
là on voit un tournant peut-être une
prise de conscience sur le nucléaire je
pense que ce sera pas le cas mais
effectivement il ya une nécessité quand
même d'investir plus dans les
renouvelables et de diversifier les les
fournisseurs et après il ya d'autres
pays d'europe centrale ou d'europe du
sud et l'est comme la bulgarie ou
d'autres qu'il a pour des raisons plus
géographique sont très dépendants
vis-à-vis de la russie donc ce sera la
tâche est longue je pense que c'est
absolument indispensable de faire ces
700 millions d'euros aujourd'hui qu'ils
vont par jour à la russie ce qui est un
butin que le pays utilise aujourd'hui
pour financer pour financer la guerre
donc c'est important à la fois pour des
raisons morales mais aussi pour des non
stratégique pour l'union européenne de
se rendre en dépenses à terme et c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs juste un point à
rajouter là-dessus je crois que l'un des
défis aujourd'hui on sait que l'europe a
réagi très rapidement
qu'ils aient une forte mobilisation
aujourd'hui des gouvernements comme des
sociétés civiles pour soutenir l'ukraine
mais évidemment ce ce conflit nous amène
sur le temps long on voit que les
ukrainiens résiste que vladimir poutine
a sous-estimé la résistance que ce
conflit peut durer peut-être des mois
qui sait des années et donc la question
pour nous c'est ce qu'on sera toujours
là en trois mois dans six mois dans un
an et que ces mesures à la fois sur la
défense et sur l'indépendance
énergétique seront vraiment suivies
d'effet sur le long terme christian il
ya un point absolument essentiel dans
tout ce que vous venez d'évoquer
benjamins moins de la vie c'est que on
n'a absolument pas compris le
fonctionnement du système politique de
quasi dictatorial en tout cas
extrêmement autoritaire russe on a pensé
en allemagne mais aussi en france avec
angie qui est partie prenante au gazoduc
du gazoduc north avec beaucoup d'autres
sociétés françaises thales qui fournit
des systèmes de navigation à certains
chasseurs russes il faut quand même le
dire on a exporté et c'est parce qu'il
avait un credo derrière tout ça qui
était celui qui est d'ailleurs à la au
fondement de l'union européenne quand on
fait du commerce ensemble on ne se fait
plus la guerre eh bien c'est faux c'est
complètement faux et ça c'est absolument
tragique et ça remet en cause
profondément la construction européenne
essalouh ça oblige tous les concessions
allemandes qui ne dépassant pas par
l'armée et c'était vraiment mis sur le
commerce et faisant tout à fait
autrement dit plus on en crève poutine
avec ses intérêts au système occidental
- il était susceptible d'être offensif
agressif vis-à-vis de nous oui mais la
russie a arbitré il y à des siècles
entre ses intérêts économiques et la
rigidité du pouvoir elle a toujours
préféré la raideur du pouvoir à ses
intérêts économiques car ça a toujours
été un pays c'est une constante
historique plus pauvres que la moyenne
des autres pays de l'europe il faut
quand même le rappeler est une poutine
n'est pas sorti de cette loi historique
au contraire il l'a renforcée donc je
pense qu'il faut vraiment méditer ça sur
les fondements européen et imaginez on
l'a dit eh ben on va le répéter tant pis
imaginez leur a beaucoup plus désormais
comme une puissance ça veut dire
question que se pose la question de la
présence de total par exemple en russie
ben en tout cas si on travaille avec eux
il faut pas en tirer une conclusion
politique il faut faire du business il
faut il n'y a pas de raison que total
ne l'utilisent pas à ses capacités
technologiques pour travailler avec les
russes parce qu'il ya quand même des
normes en jeu surtout dans le nord ce
qu'on appelle par extension le pôle nord
il ya beaucoup de possibilités
ça fait travailler l'innovation
technologique et c'est pourquoi pas mais
il faut pas en tirer des conclusions
politiques ans encore moins stratégiques
ce qu'a fait quand même madame merkel
qui était de l'ess qui parlait
parfaitement russe faut rappeler aussi
le monsieur poutine parle parfaitement
allemand entre eux y avait un confort
en tout cas culturel qui leur permettait
de kiaka père n'est à mon avis les
allemandes mais nous aussi les français
les italiens beaucoup sur l'italie est
un très gros exportateurs en revenant il
faut pas confondre les choses la russie
n'est pas susceptible d'être amadouer
voit bien l'esprit alors la question des
sanctions je vous propose d'en parler
rapidement dans ce débat est d'abord on
est tous en écoutant le secrétaire
d'état chargé des affaires européennes
clément bonne stay ce matin sur bfm ce
qui a été discuté avec nos partenaires
du g7 pour avoir le plus d'effet
possible ce sont les nouvelles sanctions
si peu l'interdiction d'export de biens
de luxe qui vont frapper les oligarques
ce n'est pas anecdotique très important
aussi le retrait de ce qu'on appelle un
peu techniquement les préférences
commerciales que la russie a aujourd'hui
ça sert membres de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce ça veut dire que la
russie bénéficie de certaines facilités
pour commercer avec nous pas de droits
de douane sur certains produits parce
qu'elle est membre de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce avec les américains
avec les britanniques avec d'autres pays
du g7 tous les européens nous sommes en
train de retirer cet avantage aux russes
apport surtout le commerce de la russie
ces massifs nous allons aussi
aujourd'hui discuter sans doute
interdire les importations ces massifs
pour les russes aussi d'acier et
d'aluminium mais pour l'instant
évidemment il ya toujours
le commerce qui concerne le gaz et le
pétrole vous nous avez donné chiffre
tout à l'heure benjamin haddad les
exportations de matières premières de
russie vers les pays occidentaux ces 700
millions de dollars par jour je dis bien
par jour pascal janin est ce qu'on
touche pas les limites quand même de
cette stratégie on se pose la question
comment arrêter poutine évidemment
collectivement mais est ce que on touche
pas les limites de la stratégie des
sanctions pour l'arrêter alors les
sanctions on a toujours dit que c'était
pas forcément l'alpha et l'oméga de la
la deûle à la politique sauf que quand
vous décidez de ne pas faire une
intervention militaire face à une guerre
pour pas être belligérants vous même
vous faites quoi pour essayer de
contenir un pays dans le don le chef a
décidé de rayer de la carte un autre
état et dont on ne sait pas s'il
s'arrêtera là puisque à partir de là il
ya d'autres endroits où il ne peut y
avoir d des russes des pays qui sent pas
à la convenance de monsieur poutine donc
voit donc qu'il est la réponse que le
qu'on peut faire donc on a eu une
réponse coordonnée avec les américains
rapide unis en europe où il n'y a pas eu
de gens qui se sentent bien dans mes
moyens mais intérêts machin etc il ya
une réponse unie donc on peut pas dire
que ça pas été à la hauteur maintenant
ya une question oui mais si on parlait
du temps long
à une question sur l'europe qui ne se
pose pas pour les états unis qui sont
loin géographiquement c'est la
dépendance la dépendance en matière de
défense la dépendance en matière
énergétique
ça c'est primordial parce que ça veut
dire que si l'europe veut être capable
d'avoir puissance elle a déjà sur le
droit sur d'autres choses mais une vraie
puissance il va falloir qu'elle se
réveille peut-être d'une torpeur qu'elle
avait depuis l'origine parce qu'il y
avait plus de guerre on avait construit
l'europe en 1950 avec plus jamais ça on
s'est réconcilié avec les allemands 5
ont signé avec tous les pays avec lequel
elle avait fait des guerres au coin du
ciel y avait plus de guerre dont la paix
et on n'avait pas vu que la défense la
défense tous les pays européens sauf la
france et la grèce et quelques autres
s'étaient endormis belle au bois dormant
disent rien n'arrivera jamais plus rien
et ben voilà on se réveille aujourd'hui
un peu brutalement avec des changements
à faire est donc là il va falloir se
réveiller pour en effet de plus dépendre
des américains ou d'autres forces pour
la défense et de la russie pour pour
l'énergie est bien évidemment ça va
demander du temps parce que bien entendu
tout ça fasse pas se faire du jour au
lendemain et puis en effet la finalité
c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait de tout ça
pour qu'on ait fait ça serve à l'europe
le jour où on aura besoin d'en avoir
besoin pour défendre les intérêts qui
sont les nôtres face à un agresseur qui
peut être tiers il n'y a pas de voie là
oui les choses qu'il faut pas
sous-estimer effectivement déjà ce qui a
été fait très rapidement par les
européens ricains pour accroître le coût
de l'agression de la russie à la fois
sur le plan économique on est en train
d'isoler le régime économiquement
diplomatiquement on a quand même
sérieusement érodé les marges de
manoeuvre budgétaires de vladimir
poutine avec les sanctions sur la banque
centrale le rule est en train de
s'effondrer donc tout ça ça va avoir un
impact ça va prendre du temps mais
clairement il est sous pression on a les
ukrainiens avec des pays qui ont rompu
des tabous comme la suède et l'allemagne
sur le sujet donc ça c'est quand même
effectivement assez important mais c'est
vrai qu'au delà des mesures à prendre il
ya il faut complètement changer de
logiciel intellectuelle ses logiciels
dans lequel on est depuis trente ans
c'est à dire que ya un paradoxe en fait
effectivement est ce que c'est ce que
vous avez dit l'union européenne était
un succès politique extraordinaire pour
les pays européens mais parfois nous
prépare mal affronter en revanche le
reste du monde qui est toujours dans une
logique de rapport de force le rapport
de puissance et d'instrumentalisation
des intérêts et des liens économiques à
des fins de puissance ce que disait
christian tout à l'heure deux ans avant
la première guerre mondiale le plus
grands best-sellers en europe c'est un
livre de norman angels qui s'appelle la
grande illusion et qui dit que la guerre
est impossible à cause de
l'interdépendance économique entre les
états européens ce qui avait déjà une
vague de mondialisation
au tournant du 19e et du 20e siècle ait
fallu attendre les années 70-80 pour
voir un tel taux des changes
internationale que celui qu'on a vu en
1913 ça n'a évidemment pas empêché la
guerre et pourtant on a eu la même
illusion dans les années 1990 avec la
rue si vous en avez parlé bien sûr dans
les liens entre l'allemagne et la russie
s'est très bien entendu avec la chine
c'était c'était la fin de l'histoire
c'était une idée des normes libérales
qui allait s'étendre à travers le monde
et on a fait rentrer la chine dans le mc
on s'est dit ben finalement il ya un
début de libéralisme économique en chine
donc forcément le politique va suivre ça
va être une libéralisation une
démocratisation politique et donc en
ancrant la chine au système économique
international
on va la voir s'ouvrir qu'est ce qu'on
voit au contraire un durcissement
autoritaire et unité une utilisation par
la chine de ses liens avec des pays
notamment via les routes de la soie à
des fins de puissance géopolitique donc
là alors nous il faut pas forcément
qu'on s'inspire totalement du même
modèle on a nos propres valeurs on a nos
normes à défendre mais il faut qu'on
comprenne comment les autres autour de
nous fonctionne et qu'on arrive à
s'adapter les logiques de puissance il
faut en développer les instruments ça
prend du temps effectivement vous l'avez
dit sur le plan énergétique comme lui
sur le plan de défense
ça demande vraiment là un changement de
logiciel la france à mon avis un peu
mieux outillés a pu mieux armé que
certains de ses partenaires comme
l'allemagne parce qu'on n'a jamais
complètement abandonné à cette réflexion
stratégique clairement en france et au
contraire on essayait de pousser depuis
quelques années nos pays à nos
partenaires à réfléchir à développer
l'autonomie stratégie de l'union
européenne projette boussole qui
équipent élément qui était un petit peu
branlante certains disaient on a
maintenant aujourd'hui tout le monde est
avec la france et les autres pays qui la
porte parce que là on n'ait fini à une
urgence tout le projet qui était un vrai
révolution aussi à travers une première
étape dans cette chaleur en france on va
parler ensemble de la chine justement
parce qu'il ya une rencontre aujourd'hui
entre des hauts diplomates chinois et
américains qui se déroule à rome le new
york times affirmait que moscou avait
demandé une aide militaire et économique
chinoise en réponse aux sanctions
occidentales contre la guerre en ukraine
le porte parole du ministère chinois des
affaires étrangères dénonce une
désinformation de la part des états unis
en écoute
récemment les états unis ont diffusé une
série de fausses nouvelles visant la
chine sur la question de l'ukraine avec
des intentions malveillantes
la position de la chine sur la question
de l'ukraine a été claire et cohérente
nous avons toujours joué un rôle
constructif en appelant à la paix et aux
négociations la question la plus urgente
à l'heure actuelle est que toutes les
parties fassent preuve de retenue
refroidissement de la situation tendue
au lieu de jeter de l'huile sur le feu
et favorise une résolution diplomatique
au lieu d'aggraver la situation
alors je voudrais vous entendre les uns
les autres des réponses assez court
parce qu'il reste un peu là je voudrais
qu'on évoque aussi la stratégie de
poutine là sur le terrain en ce moment
ce qu'on appelle là ce que jean yves le
drian pas appel la guerre à la guerre de
siège dans les grandes villes sur la
stratégie chinoise et les quoi partager
la chine est ce que ça peu ce conflit
plats servis
et que jusque là la chine était ciblé
par trump par obama d'abord puis par
train puis par maiden et là elle obtient
un desserrement de l'étau puisque
l'attention se porte sur la russie ce
qui était aussi par ailleurs une volonté
de poutine de revenir dans le jeu et le
définir non pas comme un duo entre
washington et pékin mais un trio entre
washington moscou et pékin donc la chine
pour le moment cherche surtout à avoir
de l'importance dans ma vie dans le
schéma de sortie de crise c'est rien
pour laquelle elle va laisser la crise
complètement se dérouler et si elle est
à l'avantagé de la russie ça ne gênera
absolument pas la créa la chine qui
pensera bien sûr peut-être à taïwan etc
mais pour l'instant la chine joue un
attentisme assez pervers pour nous dire
qu'ils risquent de nous ménager quelques
surprises je crois pas du tout à cette
histoire je vais très brèves de deux des
deux demandés par la russie à la chine
ne serait ce que parce que la russie a
exporté du matériel en chine des sukhoï
35 par exemple sont des chasseurs assez
performant et ensuite la russie a arrêté
parce qu'elle s'est plainte de
l'espionnage industriel effectuée par la
chine parce qu'elle voit dans votre avis
sur la stratégie chinoise tels que
choisir a participé à l'isolément de
poutine ou alors pas du tout comment
vous les verrez ce que c'est très
factuelle et puis je pense que c'est
même à double tranchant parce que
contrairement à ce que croient ils ne
s'aiment pas la chine et la russie ils
sont tous les deux dans des optiques
dans pire c'est pas la même civilisation
poutine déteste les chinois alors si en
effet factuellement momentanément il
peut trouver un partenaire qui parce
qu'il a déjà plein de conflits ailleurs
et il a les états unis l'europe qui le
met c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas de
puissance qui peuvent s'entendre et puis
il ya décalage c'est que il ya une
puissance en croissant jallet puis dire
et l'autre plutôt en décroissance la
russie avec une population qui est très
faible à vieillissement une situation
sanitaire vent qui est dans les deux cas
peut-être un peu dangereuse mais les
deux la seule chose qu'ils aimeraient si
vous voulez c'est si on pouvait dégommer
l'europe ce truc qui n'est pas un état
qui n'est pas unie sert donc nous on a
par contre à se méfier et des russes et
des chinois et qui porte les valeurs de
la démocratie et la démocratie
cette rencontre n'a jamais atteint entre
haut diplomate chinois et américains à
rome qu'elle
quel impact ça peut avoir sur le conflit
entre la russie et l'ukraine alors ça
c'est intéressant parce que les
américains donc on fait fuiter dans la
presse cette histoire de russie qui se
tourner vers la chine pour demander des
armements jusqu'ici il faut quand même
reconnaître que les américains sont
plutôt pas trompé en ce qui concerne le
renseignement sur l'ukraine cd1 semaines
donc il faut le prendre au sérieux et si
une façon peut-être pour eux de mettre
la pression sur la chine on verra si la
chine si cette information est avérée on
verra sur la chine considéré que c'est
dans son intérêt de rentrer d'une salle
face on a directement dans ce conflit en
soutenant militairement la russie j'en
suis pas sûr mais ce qui est certain
c'est que la russie s'est mis elle-même
dans une relation de dépendance et de
vassalité biais de la chine en
choisissant la voie de l'agression en
tournant le dos à l'europe et mêmes aux
états unis parce que regarder l'an
dernier juste après son élection en joe
biden quelques mois plus tard se rend
pour son premier déplacement en europe
il va voir les européens effet le sommet
du g7 et après il fait un sommet
bilatéral avec vladimir poutine à genève
pour parler des contrôles d'armement
donc la stratégie américaine vise la
russie sous byden c'était plutôt des si
c'est ce qu'ils appelaient d'avoir une
relation stable et prévisible pour
pouvoir pivoter vers l'asie pacifique et
se concentrer sur l'art de la rivalité
stratégique avec la chine donc
effectivement pour l'instant voir les
américains rappelés en europe est plutôt
dans l'intérêt de la chine parce qu'on
parle plus de la de plastique on parle
plus de taiwan et on va les américains
un peu district doit même renvoyer des
troupes dans les pays de l'otan pour
faire de la réassurance en pologne dans
les états baltes ou en roumanie si les
tensions augmentent notamment sur
l'économie mondiale là ça devient quand
même un petit peu plus embarrassant je
pense pour les décideurs à beijing et
mais effectivement c'est la russie
elle-même acquise éminent une relation
aujourd'hui de dépendance de vassalité
ça fait des années qu'on dit d'ailleurs
belle macro et d'autres mettent en garde
le dirigeant russe contre cette relation
mais aujourd'hui il a pas d'autre issue
s'il veut par exemple pouvoir échapper
aux sanctions que d'essayer de se
tourner vers la chine quelques minutes
pour conclure autour de la stratégie de
la dir poutine avec d'abord cette
déclaration du ministre français des
affaires étrangères jean yves le drian
pessimiste ce matin c'était sur france
inter la russie et les forces russes
sont entrés dans une logique de guerre
que j'ai appelé tout à l'heure la guerre
des sièges c'est ce que l'on voit
kharkiv c'est ce que l'on voit marioupol
c'est ce qu'on risque de voir à odessa
et c'est ce qu'on risque de voir kiev
mais cette logique de sièges c'est une
grande habitude
la manière dans les russes font la
guerre on a eu les précédents de grosses
ni et d'alep nous sommes devant un mur
une logique de sièges qui risque de
durer longtemps si bien que devant cette
situation je pense que le pire est
encore devant nous logique de deux
sièges effectuant sait pas vraiment qui
semble qu'un changement de stratégie
c'était prévisible mais dans les
premiers jours on imaginait une guerre
éclair ce à quoi fait penser cette
logique de guerre des sièges d'une
guerre des villes c'est quand même
connaît plutôt dans un plan b voire dans
un plan c'est que dans le plan à à mon
avis c'est que ça ressemble quand même à
un constat d'échec de l'opération rêvée
par tous militaires qui est une
opération blitzkrieg
c'est quand même le rêve de tout
académie militaire c'est le blitzkrieg
un biskri qui serait qui aurait permis
d'arriver à kiev etc il ya une étape
tous les jours charrie son lot
d'horreurs de bombardement et ces images
absolument insoutenable mais on oublie
un détail c'est que dans les premiers
jours quelque chose de très important
s'est passé sur l'aéroport qui se trouve
au nord de kiev que les reports de host
aux mails ou gosse domaine en russe
là les russes devaient prendre cet
aéroport qui aurait servi de point de
ravitaillement avec un véritable pont
aérien tout près de kiev et puis la
faire huer été réglé en quelques jours
or c'est un repas était surprennent pas
surprise
repris par les ukrainiens puis repris
par les russes qui en le reprenant lanto
totalement détruit donc il est inutile
inutilisable et à partir de là on a vu
les photos les images des files de
camions sur une seule voie avec laquelle
le de 60 km les difficultés
d'approvisionnement des soldats qui
n'arrivaient plus nourriture et qui
volait dans les résultats si ce qu'on
appelle
des gels quoi sert elle à bout c'est la
boue spécifique de la russie qui durent
des semaines et des semaines et qui a
une profondeur qu'on ne connaît pas ici
à l'europe occidentale
c'est à dire ça joue un mauvais tour à
deux types lyon et l'autre hitler
toujours se souvenir de l'histoire et la
cei il commençait et il commence à y
être ça y est la rescousse de sa
commence et
de toute façon on voit clairement que
l'opération ville est une sorte de
d'opérations de de second temps décidé
cette fois à terroriser les populations
et effectivement le ministre le drian a
raison ça rappelle alep comme ça
rappelle grossemy mais c'était sûrement
pas le rêve du chef d'état major des
forces armées russes qui s'appelle
générale valérie guerre asimov c'était
sûrement pas son intention initiale d'un
an est-ce qu'il faut il voir plus qu'un
échec russe je ne sais pas le benjamin
haddad le pentagone parle de troupes
russes qui se saborde pour ne pas
combattre on peut les croire oui parce
que le moral des troupes russes et très
mauvais d'après ce qu'on en sait on
parle aussi de désertion visiblement les
rues les soldats russes ne savais même
pas qu'ils devaient aller combattre ces
terres qui ont été très surpris vladimir
poutine et essayer de cacher en fait
cette opération ce vraiment à son
entourage le plus proche on leur a dit
qu'ils faisaient partie d'un exercice
militaire c'est ce concert de la 2d
débrief des prisonniers de guerre russe
aujourd'hui en ukraine ils ont été
stupéfaits et on leur a dit qu'ils
devaient combattre la nation soeur
puisque c'était la propagande
russe déjà dans les mois qui ont précédé
envoie aussi qu'ils ont eu des
difficultés logistiques ils ont
sous-estimé la résistance des ukrainiens
ils ont sous-estimé aussi la résilience
de du président alain ski c'est ce que
disait christian vaquin dans le plan a
visiblement c'est un raid éclair sur
kiev pour essayer de décapiter
leadership politique on pensait que les
militaires ukrainien allait peut-être
renverser le président ou qu'il allait
fuir ou que tous allaient s'effondrer
comme un château de cartes s'effondre il
allait en fait l'outil nécessaire qui
était assez étonnant il est justement
très mal informée ne comprends pas
l'ukraine et c'est aujourd'hui pour ça
malheureusement qu'on voit une montée en
violences contre les civils qui a très
bien décrit le ministre le drian merci
beaucoup à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat benjamin l'aise rappel le titre de
votre livre le paradis perdu l'amérique
de trump et la fin des illusions
européennes
publié chez grasset demain